- This video is brought to
you by Full Sail University.
(upbeat music)
What's up, guys?
Michael here to talk about
the original content behemoth, Netflix.
Once chiefly a purveyor of
movies in red envelopes,
Netflix has quickly established itself
as the film studio of the future,
releasing a staggering 129
original films in 2021 alone,
and the pipeline isn't
slowing down any time soon.
But as you get flooded with trailers
for their latest movies,
maybe you've wondered,
"Do all of these films
kind of look the same?"
Don't worry, you don't need new glasses.
Netflix does tend to hew
to a unique look and feel.
And, what's more, the Netflix aesthetic
has real implications for
the film medium at large.
We'll explain in this Wisecrack Edition:
How Netflix is Changing Film.
But before we get into it,
I wanna tell you about today's sponsor,
Full Sail University.
What's up, guys?
I am in Winter Park, Florida
today at Full Sail University.
We are here for their Hall
of Fame Celebration Week
and let's go check it out.
Full Sail University specializes
in preparing students for careers
in the entertainment industry,
emerging technologies,
and gaming, to name a few.
And because they have so
many successful graduates,
they spend a full week every
year celebrating these alumni
during Hall of Fame Week.
We were lucky enough to
spend some time at Full Sail
during the Hall of Fame Celebration.
The campus was absolutely
buzzing with activity.
As students were checking
out panel discussions
with new Hall of Fame inductees,
enjoying an afternoon at the silent disco,
and prepping for the
annual cosplay competition.
We also checked out some of
the amazing resources available
to Full Sail students.
They also unveiled their brand-new
virtual production studio
during Hall of Fame Week,
and we were lucky enough
to attend the ribbon-cutting ceremony,
as well as get in the exclusive tour
to see Studio V1 in action.
This is the same type of technology used
to make shows like "The Mandalorian,"
and Full Sail students
will have the opportunity
to use this studio in their
own creative projects.
I even got to jump on their
Hall of Fame livestream,
which they run throughout the week
to highlight all the
alumni and special events.
Okay, guys, if you wanna learn more
about everything happening
here at Full Sail,
head to fullsail.edu or click
the link in the description,
and now, back to the show.
Over the past few years,
Netflix has solidified its move
from giant movie platform
to gianter movie maker,
adding plenty of popular
and profitable titles in its library.
And they've got range:
from foreign language prestige pictures
like Ramin Bahrani's "The White Tiger,"
to action westerns like
"The Harder They Fall,"
to the vaguely disturbing "Gerald's Game."
At first glance, these films
don't seem to have all
that much in common.
But dig a little deeper,
and you'll find plenty of
aesthetic similarities.
Take the cinematography.
It tends to feel very slick,
manufactured, and smooth.
Even Bahrani, who previously
made a name for himself
directing gritty, realistic dramas,
essentially subsumed his
style into this cleaner look.
Netflix films also tend to
share a similar color scheme,
with deeply-saturated hues
that render the actors
practically phosphorescent,
and make the slums of
India or a Wild West saloon
look almost as lush as the
mansions in "He's All That."
At the same time, the images
are relatively low-contrast,
making them easy, even
pleasant, on the eyes.
Even the use of focus
tends to be pretty uniform,
often evoking a glamorous softness
that would have been standard fare
for, say, a 1940s melodrama.
So what is this look really amounting to?
Let's examine the sum of the parts:
slick, functional cinematography;
low-contrast lighting;
saturated, matte colors;
and simple, no-nonsense compositions.
This all makes for an easy, comfortable,
non-confrontational aesthetic.
Which is to say,
it's basically ideal
for passive consumption
while folding your
freshly-laundered collection
of Wisecrack T-shirts.
The passivity these films mostly engender
seem to be part of the point.
As Matt Singer writes for ScreenCrush,
"It's not that these Netflix
movies can't be enjoyed
while you are distracted by
your phone or your tablet;
it's that they are
undeniably better that way."
Of course, there are exceptions.
For example, prestige films
made by big-name directors
like Martin Scorsese's "The Irishman"
or Alfonso Cuaron's "Roma."
But, more than anything,
these exceptions only make
the overall house style
of the platform stand out even more.
Compare the richness of the colors
in "The Irishman's" film photography,
or the expansive scope of
"Roma's" wide-screen framing
to your average Netflix original,
and you'll see just how
different these movies are
from the norm.
And the Netflix norm when it
comes to style of filmmaking
is actually ideal for how
the site itself is built.
Namely, the fact that Netflix hinges
on a very specific type
of cinematic experience:
one that never ends.
How many times have you just finished
watching a great movie on Netflix,
soaking it all in as the credits roll,
only to be snapped out of it
the moment the trailer
for "Tall Girl" pops up?
Obviously, Netflix wants people to watch
as many of their films as possible,
so auto-playing a new
flick ASAP helps with that.
This all leads into the effects
of Netflix's algorithmization
of its films.
You already know about Netflix's
famous embedded algorithm
that tracks the content you
watch, among other things,
so that it can recommend
other movies and shows
you're also likely to enjoy.
And what's an easy,
and almost subconscious,
way of convincing you
that you'll enjoy the next recommendation?
If, at first glance,
this new film looks like
the last thing you watched.
And that's what makes this trend
towards homogenous aesthetics
such a valuable tool.
Now, there is an argument
to be made that algorithms
can actually be more
democratic than curation.
Instead of relying on critics
or that film school hipster
you went on a date with,
AI uses your own personal taste
to determine what movies
are worth your time.
But while this sounds great in theory,
the actual result doesn't
always work out that way.
In practice, algorithms often
skew rather conservatively.
That is to say, they tend to rely
on a known quantity of
data they have about you,
rather than risk surprising
you with an outlier
that might not suit your taste.
In other words, if the platform detects
that you have previously enjoyed
films like "Mystic River,"
"Se7en," and "The Shawshank Redemption,"
then the algorithm will take
a lot of factors into account
in order to cater to your tastes.
Which probably means they
won't suggest you watch,
say, "Paddington 2," which is a shame,
because that movie is a masterpiece.
And when we say they'll take
a lot of factors into account,
we are not kidding.
As Todd Yellin, Netflix's VP
of Product told WIRED magazine,
the algorithm is able to split users
into 2,000 different taste groups
based on the explicit and implicit data
that each user had shown.
That includes both data
actively given by you,
like a thumbs up rating,
or passive data collected,
like your infinite scrolling
through Oscar-contenders,
or the time you binged
"Squid Game" in one week.
Now, this system sounds
sophisticated enough,
but it can still easily fall
prey to algorithmic bias.
It's pretty convenient
and generally pleasant
to receive more movie
recommendations that remind you of...
- [David Mills] What's in the box?
But it can also lead to a feedback loop.
Scholar Dal Yong Jin argues
that the algorithm's goal
of serving up a new movie
that you're certain to like
functionally limits your opportunities
to explore films in a
variety of genres or themes.
What's more, the algorithm
typically keeps viewers
culturally confined by,
for example, mostly
recommending American films
to American viewers.
What's the point of paying for access
to a gargantuan library
if you're functionally never
going to expand your horizons?
But when this starts feeling even more sus
is the fact that the
algorithmization of Netflix
extends far beyond your personal queue.
It can actually affect
the new works of art
that are being produced.
Way back in 2018,
former VP of original content
Cindy Holland told Vulture
that Netflix was greenlighting projects
based on 70% human analysis
and 30% data from the algorithm.
Data including specifics
like how long you watched a given film,
whether you stopped watching
because it was too scary,
and whether you stuck around
to start yet another scary movie
only to step away like a little coward...
or maybe that's just me.
Anyway, we suspect that
data has been given
an even more privileged position
at Netflix in recent years,
but call that speculation.
Now, it's one thing when film tropes
evolve naturally through popular culture.
But when the computer
starts playing storyteller,
we get a little shiver down our spine.
It's not that it's dystopian.
I mean, it might be,
but it's also often bad.
Take the new Ryan Reynolds
film "The Adam Project,"
which Vulture perfectly described as
feeling like a fake movie,
designed to check as many
genre boxes as possible
to maximize its chance of success.
But critical misfires
like superhero-time-traveling-Ryan
Reynolds
encountering his childhood self
can't stop Netflix's algorithm,
estimated to be worth a cool $1 billion.
It's clearly seen as valuable
for its ability to predict
what people will want to watch
based on what they've previously enjoyed.
And, to state the obvious,
this isn't entirely unique in
the entertainment industry.
Studios have always used
past successes and failures
when deciding what to make next,
or when predicting box-office hits.
But obviously, Netflix has
the great gift of big data
to make those decisions more
approximate, more scientific,
and ultimately, less risky.
Which is why some of the rest of Hollywood
has been taking note and
starting to consult AI
during the film development phase.
What's more, Netflix arguably
has more sway and
influence over the industry
than just about any other company.
That's perhaps why we see its aesthetic
making its way into the industry at large.
So, what does it mean when Netflix
makes its content decisions
in tandem with an algorithm
that's predicated on your
previous cinematic taste?
Well, when you're more worried
about holding attention
and keeping butts on couches
than you are about making good art,
you arguably lose much of
what makes cinema so important
in the first place: the risk factor.
See, most films that are truly
provocative and compelling
probably wouldn't make it through
the old Netflix algorithm.
The reason cult classics
are usually delightful
is their sheer shock value.
(everyone screaming)
Would Netflix greenlight a
film starring an unknown actor,
about a curly-haired weirdo in Idaho
who plays tetherball all day?
Heck, would a retelling of the "Odyssey"
set in Depression-era America
sound sexy to an algorithm?
And how would something
as weird as "Tree of Life"
ever possibly make it past
Netflix's head of content?
Now, it's no surprise that
in our TikTok-happy culture,
commercial filmmaking in general
has become more preoccupied
with keeping you from looking away
via high-voltage special effects,
laser-fast editing cuts, and so on.
But we think algorithms
take it one step farther
when they assume that
we're only down to watch
what we've already
watched, but regurgitated.
Of course, there's a
decent argument to be made
that much of cinematic history
has been somewhat self-cannibalizing.
And you don't have to
look at four generations
of "A Star is Born" for evidence.
The assembly-line logic that
fueled Hollywood's golden era
often meant rearranging
your contract actors
in various trope-ish roles
like strong silent type,
or the manipulative vamp,
or the plucky young innocents.
These characters would
then, almost inevitably,
go through storylines of
lost love, love regained,
and hey, maybe there's a peppy
musical number in there, too.
Still, Hollywood nonetheless exhibited
what scholar Janet Staiger called,
"A drive towards product differentiation,
stressing novelty, and innovation
in order to lure audiences to
the cinema again and again."
They needed people to be
actively excited to watch.
Netflix doesn't have the same burden.
It's often the background
soundtrack to your domestic life.
And arguably what keeps
you from turning it off
is familiarity or sameness.
That is, entertainment that reminds you
of previously-enjoyable entertainment,
or as we like to call it: algortainment.
Is that not catchy?
Is it not?
Well, okay, I'll never say it again.
We can understand this
via the philosophical
movement of Postmodernism,
and its application to aesthetics,
which has been percolating
in academia since the '70s.
Postmodernism is predicated
on the notion that society
has become so fragmented
that there's been a
breakdown in subjectivity,
i.e., there is no longer any
consistent and universal truth
that grounds how we view
art or our own subjectivity.
If we used to all have a loose agreement
on what counted as art, or cinema,
we're now in a free-for-all,
where a TikTok is as
valid as a Scorsese film.
This comes with challenges.
As literary critic
Fredric Jameson explains,
"If, indeed, the subject
has lost its capacity
to organize its past and future
into coherent experience,
it becomes difficult enough
to see how the cultural productions
of such a subject could result in anything
but heaps of fragments."
In other words, when it no longer feels
like there are universal
truths and concepts
that help you make consistent
sense of experience over time,
it's harder to turn your
unique experiences into art.
And it's even harder for a bunch of folks
with disparate experiences
and perspectives
to all agree on what art
even is in the first place,
let alone, agree on what
art is actually good.
So, where do we get the raw material
to create those heaps of fragments?
We start pillaging dead
artists, of course!
As Jameson puts it, in the postmodern era,
"The producers of culture
have nowhere to turn
but to the past: the
imitation of dead styles,
speech through all the masks
and voices stored up
in the imaginary museum
of a now global culture."
He calls the practice of invoking
or straight-up reviving old
styles of art, pastiche,
and considers it a fundamental tool
of making postmodern art.
Of course, pastiche isn't
necessarily a bad thing.
Without pastiche, you
wouldn't have "Pulp Fiction,"
or the novels of Thomas Pynchon,
or the sparkly '60s camp of "Hairspray."
The postmodern turn reveled in the idea
that no piece of art is purely creative,
that we're all cross-inspired
by other artists:
past, present and future.
And postmodern artists
used various techniques
of ripping each other off to
make truly groundbreaking work
as wide ranging as "Blue Velvet"
and "Monty Python and the Holy Grail."
But not all works of postmodern
art can be brilliant.
Jameson acknowledged that postmodernism
necessarily implied a
sort of cultural stasis.
And in that stasis,
"The supreme value of
the new and of innovation
fades away against the steady stream
of momentum and variation
that at some outer limit
seems stable and motionless.
Where everything now submits
to the perpetual change
of fashion and media image,
nothing can change any longer."
So you get a lot of sameness,
and a lack of new
coherent artistic styles.
Simultaneously, as Jameson explains,
"What has happened is that
aesthetic production today
has become integrated into
commodity production generally,"
and now faces "The
frantic economic urgency
of producing fresh waves of
ever-more-novel-seeming goods
at ever greater rates of turnover."
In this way, whereas art objects
used to have value
relative to their beauty
or aesthetic style,
they are now simply commodities
to be produced and sold.
It's not shocking that Jameson
once defined postmodernism as,
"The cultural logic of late capitalism."
So, just as originality
has slumped to a crawl,
demand for production has skyrocketed.
And who does that remind us of?
Our good red-enveloped friend, of course.
Now, to be clear, Netflix
hasn't dedicated itself
to the postmodern project
the way that the cool
kids at art school have.
They're just trying to get
more eyes on their movies
for longer periods of time.
To be clear, we're not saying
all movies used to be masterpieces.
Some cinema used to try to be art,
while some was content
being popcorn blockbusters.
And Netflix has tried both strategies
to amass its giant
portfolio of original work,
all in attempts to
achieve its supreme goal
of maximizing watch time.
It's not even up to us to say
if that came at the expense of quality,
because Netflix's COO Ted Sarandos
has implied as much himself.
In response to critics panning
Netflix's film "Bright,"
Sarandos defended the film,
saying that critics, "Speak
to specific audiences
who care about quality,
or how objectively good or bad
a movie is, not the masses."
Implying, of course,
that the masses don't care
about objective quality,
and that Netflix is okay
not actually delivering it.
This reminds us of philosopher
Theodor Adorno's critique
of mid-20th century popular music.
As scholar C.W. Smith explains,
Adorno believed that people
were listening to popular music
without actually listening
because they were
experiencing what he called,
"A breakdown in mediating subjectivity
or the intersubjectivity of the experience
between the subject and
the piece of music."
That is to say, people were so inundated
with homogenous pop music
that they started consuming it mindlessly,
rather than engaging with
any single song thoughtfully.
For Adorno, this was about more
than just spacing out, though.
He contended that this sort of
undiscerning consumption of art
indicated a broader social
tendency towards obedience,
even an acceptance of authoritarianism,
which can prevent us from
becoming free-thinking,
reflective individuals.
That is to say, when we
stop thinking critically
about the art we consume,
we become less autonomous
and instead more pliable,
suggestible, and easier to coerce.
The interminable sameness
Adorno observed, he believed,
led to both a, "Regression
in quality of hearing,"
and "The more or less
stunting of experience,
such that the listener was docile
and afraid of anything new."
And that sense of safety in familiarity
sounds pretty familiar when
we think about Netflix.
As we've discussed, Netflix films are made
for the sort of watching-non-watching
Adorno diagnosed
in mid-century music listeners.
And there's reason to believe viewers
might indeed be afraid of anything new.
Stephen Follows, founder
of VOD Clickstream,
which analyzes Netflix data,
argued in a podcast that
when people watch Netflix,
"They're sitting down
and watching stuff that is comfortable,
that is easy to understand,
that won't challenge them."
The appeal of the algorithm
is its infinitely watchable
lack of confrontation.
And look, we're not monsters,
we love us some easy-watching
as much as we love Frank Sinatra.
Lord knows, I've watched
the episode of "The Office"
where Dwight quotes
Mussolini about 76 times.
(podium thudding)
- Blood alone moves the wheels of history!
- But does constant easy-watching
come at the expense of our
ability to really watch?
And when arguably the world's
most powerful media
corporation commits itself
to making movies we're
all-but-guaranteed to half-watch,
does it change the way we
engage with the medium overall?
And when we consider the algorithmization
of most aspects of our modern lives,
the problem starts to feel way scarier.
But hey, at least we get
to watch "Is it Cake?"
But what do you guys think?
When it comes to Netflix films,
are we actually getting
the cinema we want,
or merely the cinema the
algorithm thinks we want?
What's more, are we inadvertently creating
our own cinematic hell when we hate-watch
some of Netflix's more mediocre content?
Let us know in the comments.
Big thanks to our patrons
for all your support.
Please go check out our
revamped Patreon page!
We have lots of good stuff in there.
Hit that subscribe button
like you're jumping up to
give the tall girl a high-five
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat electronic music)